all right get this the state police
association of massachusetts is taking
aim at republican governor charlie
baker's vaccine mandate as dozens of
officers face termination in a letter on
facebook the union president says
several legitimate exemption requests
were denied and quote these willful
attacks on public safety personnel and
the continued rush planning around the
covet 19 pandemic is putting lives at
risk and can i add this whole numbers
are in retreat especially in
massachusetts the president of the state
police association of massachusetts
sergeant mike chevron joins us now
sergeant how bad are things in
massachusetts now how many men and women
are told to go home
we're receiving letters approximately 10
to 12 a day
and they're being denied
reasonable accommodations however the
the odd part here is they're being told
that they do have a medical condition
and or a religious exemption that should
be allowed but because this
administration will not allow for our
troopers to wear a mask or get regular
testing they're going to be separated
from service either through retirement
termination or forced resignations so
you tell me the force is about 2700 down
to about 2 000 and every day more and
more names are being released of people
released from their jobs how does
massachusetts how's the state going to
respond how are the citizens affected
uh they're going to be seeing delays in
service you know this morning we're in
the middle of a uh of this storm and i
just heard on the radio they're holding
over the midnight shift in in order to
fill all the calls for service because
of downed trees flooding and and the
like and that's going to become the norm
we're going to be seeing troopers held
over uh working longer hours we're going
to have increased caseloads and the
potential there for uh you know increase
in homicide uh you know solvability
rates are going to go down thousands are
going to face the same thing november
1st right here in new york so they're
going to be joining you so uh sergeant
would was there this much concern about
the safety of first responders and
essential workers like you and your men
and women uh when this pandemic first
hit and we're still trying to find out
what it is where it's from and
scrambling to get a vaccine were people
that concerned about your welfare then
you know i think the the citizenry was
but i wouldn't say that the
administration uh was not uh they're not
as uh
at this point in time concerned with us
and other members of public safety at
the state level in massachusetts do you
think they understood what they're
getting into just because most got
vaccinated and they they thought okay
i'll force the rest but do they realize
this force needs to be a hundred percent
no i believe that's it right there i
don't believe that they truly understood
that we do have legitimate medical and
religious exemptions and they didn't
think this out and they didn't come to
the table and properly discuss this with
us and negotiate what do you say is you
just want a testing option is that what
you're hoping for
i just want the our troopers for the
ability to remain employed by wearing a
mask and have a weekly testing option
yes
the state of washington is looking at
you guys the city of chicago is looking
at you guys of course new york city is
looking at you and this governor of
massachusetts if he wins another four
years he's probably going to do that in
the state of new jersey
so we'll see people should look at
massachusetts and find out um which we
which you might be staring at sergeant
mike chevron thanks so much hopefully
there'll be sober minds and this
governor will admit when he's wrong
thank you have a good day all right hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now